bento boxes typically are super vibrant
in color and it has a lot of different
flavors hi i'm hitomi
and we're going to show you how to make
some japanese bento
bento to me is small portions of
everything you open this box and you get
to have a little bit of everything which
is perfect for someone that wants more
than just a sandwich
i appreciate my mom's cooking because
it's something that's nostalgic it's
also something that a mom that cares
about what goes into my body every lunch
that a mom makes has i feel like a lot
of feeling and love towards the food
is a new type of rice ball it's almost
like a rice sandwich every bite you get
all the flavors i actually went to
japanese school every saturday it was
nice because my mom would make me like
authentic japanese bento and one of the
memories i have is taking bento box to
my normal public school and i just
remember all the kids were like oh it's
that because it was like little cute
sushi rolls so i came home and you know
i told my mom i was like no more
seaweed no more like eggs can't have any
of that and so she started making me
these like cute pinwheel like sandwiches
to accommodate my names i want to say in
high school like kids are more willing
to try new things and everybody would be
like whoa what's that today oh i want to
try that but when i was in elementary
school it was a nightmare and there was
a lot of struggles but i look back now
and it's super awesome that i had a mom
that made me awesome lunch
my mom has always made sure to
incorporate japanese dishes in my life
in every meal which has helped me so
much to understand japanese culture and
it's really important to live in a place
where there's so many cultures but i get
to really understand where i'm from or
really where my parents are from oh yes
[Music]
you